is
moritz heart
moritz heart has done foundational work
in
data analysis privacy machine learning
with emphasis on social aspects of these
and
moritz is an old friend of the institute
he's been
participating in the programs in the
very first year the very first semester
and uh
ever since uh
listening all right can folks hear me
yeah thanks so much prasad it's a
pleasure to speak here thanks everyone
for staying uh to the end uh it's
fantastic to wrap up this uh this very
uh interesting workshop uh
congratulations to the simon's
leadership on the 10th year anniversary
i'll be talking about a line of research
that actually started at the simons
institute nine years ago
in uh one of the first programs uh in
the science institute
and that was the um
program on the theoretical foundations
of big data analysis it was very much
about scaling up data analysis
there was something called exabyte
scales roaming the earth back then um
you know if you've ever seen one and um
you know it was an opportunity for
theoreticians to learn about um machine
learning okay so it was sort of the goal
was to take some uh theoreticians like
myself at the time and teach them a
little bit about what machine learning
is about
and uh you know um you know how we do
statistics for for data analysis
and so it came to machine learning as a
bit of an outsider
and uh like many i looked at this
peculiar community and i noticed that
it's structured and organized in a
really interesting way that's kind of
unique actually to the field of machine
learning so there is on the one hand
like a you know community of
very skillful model builders that have
given us many advances in over the last
years uh you know they have all sorts of
techniques for fitting large models to
uh to data sets
and on the other hand and this community
what seems to be very important are data
sets um that are used as benchmarks okay
and usually in science we collect data
to specifically refute or test a
hypothesis right that's what
people would do but in machine learning
actually you set aside data to use them
as benchmarks okay and then machine
learning happens in some kind of
iterative loop whereby the model
builders propose a new model uh let's
call that f um they run that against the
the benchmark data set of their choice
and they observe how well it's doing
that's called a let's call it a loss
okay the loss of the model so you
observe how well your model is doing on
the on the test set okay and this could
be something like cipher or image net
typical uh uh you know image
classification benchmarks but at this
point they're really hundreds of
benchmarks in machine learning and it's
really how this community is is
organized okay so this seemed really
interesting as a way of of doing
research okay and so this is what i call
the data sets as benchmarks paradigm and
it's uh really the pillar of machine
learning research and and practice it's
how we do this right it's how we um you
know make progress in this area
and as such we're putting a whole lot of
pressure on this idea of of data sets as
benchmarks and we're asking uh data sets
to serve many vital roles in uh in the
community first one is to to sort of
organize communities with things like
vision and speech and so on this is done
often by what data sets you work on uh
implicitly these data sets sort out
problem formulation operationalize the
problem formulation so they kind of
define what we're even trying to do
they're used to measure progress they're
also used to compare with humans to sort
of give us a sense of how well we're
doing relative to humans that was what
cindel's talk was about and that also
shapes narratives about how far ai has
come or not and finally they also
interface between academia and industry
they give you sort of a code interface
and a code contract of what a model for
a certain type of problem has to do okay
but the fundamental question i want to
ask in this talk is does it work okay
does this iterative process of model
building and testing uh lead to
progress lead to scientific progress or
does it somehow go off the tracks right
does it somehow converge to like
undesirable uh you know uh scientific
outcomes um and what does it mean for
this to work okay and this is the kind
of question we started asking uh nine
years ago in this talk i'm going to give
you some theory and empirical
observations that have kind of come out
of the last nine years about what i
think is sort of this emerging signs of
data sets as benchmarks and why i think
there should be such a science too okay
so let's start with the basics uh how
many of you have seen the holdout method
at some point before
okay i think that's probably almost
everyone so
this is kind of ostensibly or at the
outset what benchmarks are based on okay
so in the hold up method you set aside a
test set or holdout set of size n drawn
from some population from some
underlying distribution let's say and
what you're going to do is you're going
to evaluate things uh you know a loss
function
on average over this data set and that's
called the empirical risk i'm going to
write that rsf that's like the average
loss of a model f on the data set on the
holdout data and you use this empirical
risk as an estimate of the risk which is
just the population expectation of the
loss of the model um on this underlying
population p okay so the empirical risk
is something you have you have the data
set on your hard disk you can evaluate
that that's something you compute the
population is not something you have
that's a theoretical construct so you uh
you're trying to get it by using the
empirical risk
and what's typically done to to argue
that some such thing works is to look at
the generalization gap which is the
difference between risk and empirical
risk it tells you how much the empirical
risk underestimates the risk and to say
that that's small okay that hopefully
you know as we're evaluating our models
um you know this generalization gap
stays small so we never really go astray
in the sense that the the the loss that
we look at on our whole data set is
close to what it should be on the on the
population
okay
and that's like one way of trying to
argue that these things go well okay
so if you do that for the holdout method
you can look at a textbook and you will
see this kind of a textbook guaranteed
for the holdout method it's saying that
if you fix k models independently of the
data
and you evaluate them on the holdout
method then the worst generalization gap
you're going to see
over these k models is root log k over n
okay
anybody have a proof idea
200 pounds yeah oh great turn up bonds
exactly so you just do hufting and union
bound
because you have iid data these things
concentrate you take a union bound over
k models uh you get the root lock k
factor um and so this might seem great
you might say okay look uh you know k uh
could be exponentially large in n we
could be evaluating all these models on
our data and we'd still be getting good
answers
and i think um you know a lot of people
looked at sort of this kind of textbook
guarantee and we're like yeah that's
that's not too bad
okay but there's a big catch
and the big catch is exactly the machine
learning happens in the loop okay and
the models are not fixed ahead of time
right we iteratively built these models
continually while like getting feedback
from the holdout data and uh this
process in a sense adaptive right we're
sort of tailoring uh the models that we
built two previous evaluations of the
test set right we're looking at like
what we got what the previous accuracy
was on the test set and then we're
changing our model based on whether it
improved or not right so we're
incorporating feedback from uh previous
uh evaluations of our models which
breaks the textbook guarantees of the
whole method right because there's no
longer independence the functions you're
evaluating depend on the data that
you're evaluating them on okay
and so this cycle is kind of the whole
point of like how we do machine learning
research like you can't specify all your
models like back in 2010 and then
collect all the data sets and see which
one one is best right that's not how we
do it this iterative process is exactly
why we're doing well right so this issue
of recognizing and addressing adaptivity
um you know this was uh what started at
the institute nine years ago this was
joint work with cynthia dwork vitelli
feldman tony pitassi omar rheingold and
aaron roth and i think tony and and
david lee are in the audience maybe um
and so we're partially inspired by this
really interesting talk by joe benjamini
called selective inference and false
discovery rate
which talked about a important problem
with statistics and it sort of drew our
attention to issues of false discovery
and how science goes wrong and it was
sort of on the heels of this whole
debate about p hacking and kind of uh
the the reliability crisis in the
sciences
and we wanted to relate these sort of
questions that were apparently very
urgent both to like the practice of
machine learning and also like concepts
from theoretical computer science that
we were familiar with okay
and so the first thing we noticed is
that if you go to the adaptive world
where models are chosen adaptively the
holdout method as it is can actually
fail pretty badly okay so if you choose
k models adaptively the error that
you're going to get or that in the worst
case is order k or sorry order square
root k over n
okay so contrast this with the log k
dependence you now get a linear
dependence on k
meaning that after a linear number of
queries in n uh you know it's it's all
over right this is pretty bad because
the test set might have
you know size ten thousand if you make
just a hundred evaluations your error
would be ten percent okay so that's
that's this is too bad too big right
and so this is tight you can find like a
sequence of models which forces this
error okay so we first realized that you
know this is kind of uh
the guarantee is very weak in the
adaptive setting
so we're asking can you do better
and in fact you can do better exploiting
a connection between stability and
generalization
what is stability mean algorithmic
stability is a notion of an algorithm
which says that if you change one data
point the learning algorithm the output
of the learning algorithm doesn't change
much so the picture is something like
this if you have an input sample s
and you change that to another input
sample s prime uh by deleting or
changing one data point your output
doesn't change much okay it won't change
much
and this is a form of robustness and
there's a you know a set of theorems in
machine learning that says stability
implies generalization okay so in other
words
overfitting is not stable
right why if you over fit to a sample
you must sort of have too much
sensitivity in one of the data points
and uh and as a result you're not uh
you're not general you're not stable
okay
so um
so overfitting is not stable this is a
general principle
and it has nothing to do with adaptivity
it works in the non-adaptive case works
uh
you know not necessarily in the adaptive
case
but we sort of observed that this uh
privacy guarantee differential privacy
that had been studied a lot in the
theory community is a sort of a strong
algorithmic stability notion it is kind
of uh you know saying that if you change
one data point the output uh you know
can only change so much in a certain
sense
and uh we proved that differential
privacy balance uh the generalization
gap even if the analyst is adaptive okay
so even if the analyst chooses models
adaptively differential privacy
you know guarantees that the
generalization gap is small
and this is really specific to the
composition properties of differential
privacy this is something where like
other stability notions might fail it
uses the fact that differential privacy
kind of composes
when under like adaptive uh behavior
okay and so there's like a nice sort of
connection between concepts from tcs and
these issues that arise in in machine
learning so what do we get out of this
connection if you let fast forward a
couple of years of research uh
eventually get some bound like this okay
so there is a holdout mechanism based on
differential privacy so that for any k
adaptively chosen models you get error k
to the one fourth over root n
okay instead of this root k over n
but this is a lot of hard work there was
a beautiful work by basili nissium smith
stammer and stank and oldman uh from
2016 that improved our earlier bounds
there's a lot of heavy machinery here
and unfortunately you can show that this
n squared that you get out of this is is
best possible okay so this is giving you
n squared um you know model evaluations
and you can show that in the worst case
that's that's tight assuming one-way
functions exist okay so there's also
hardness result which says that
not exactly this rate is optimal there
could be another rate but like more than
n squared we can't
okay
and so it might seem this is where word
ends okay so that like
we can go from n to n squared by using
these tricks from differential privacy
um but you might still say this isn't
really explained this doesn't really
explain why machine learning works
because people have been using sifar and
imagenet for like
more than a decade and it's uh you know
still going strong and they made all
these evaluations and you know if this
were the truth then we'd be in trouble i
would argue
but there's actually this is not where
it stops and you can actually go a lot
further and there's a little more recent
research that is more specific to
machine learning where you get much
better bounce okay
and so this started with work with avram
uh avram blam who's maybe still in the
audience um and uh
yeah hi abram
and so um it's what we call the
leaderboard principle
and the best way to think about this is
let's think harder about the machine
learning community and let's postulate
um about the behavior of the machine
learning community and let's make the
following postulate let's say that model
builders
are only impressed with significant
improvements over the best previous
model okay so at any point in time they
care about the number one model whatever
it is you know the best current language
model or the best current image
classifier and they try to improve upon
that okay
this is an assumption about the inner
workings of the community sort of a
sociological hypothesis right it's a
it's a it's an apostrophe right and so
let's assume this is true okay that this
community is very much obsessed with or
being being best or like improving upon
the uh the best current model
um this leads to a notion of leaderboard
error where you you have still the same
adaptive loop it's a full adaptivity but
your only goal is to maintain an
estimate of the the current best model
so at any point in time you just want to
know what is the best language model
right now i don't care about all
possible models in the world i just care
about the best model i want to know
which one is the best model and what is
the loss of the current best model
because at any point t you just want the
best model and if that's what you're
trying to do there's a very simple
algorithm that works and it goes like
this you just check if at any point in
time when somebody gives you a model you
just check if that model beats the
previous best by a margin epsilon some
some margin and if it does beat the
previous best model you update you say
congratulations jilani you you're now
number one
and uh you know if not you say sorry uh
you didn't improve and i can't tell you
your score okay
so uh either you improved by a margin
and i give you the score and say you're
number one or you didn't improve in
essay you get nothing okay you know i i
don't want to tell you what it is
because you didn't improve
and so if you if you try to work with
leaderboard error instead so you're just
trying to do this you can get much
better error bounce okay so we found
that like actually simple analysis of
this algorithm um recovers this
logarithmic dependence on k okay so you
can go again back to like logarithmic
dependence on k instead of this
polynomial dependence on k so that's an
exponential improvement in k
the rate is a little bit off and that's
been bothering me since then um and
nobody else solved this problem so
i tried to you know to work on this
myself and i came up with this uh you
know unfortunate exponent um of
two-fifths okay
so um and i think the worst or the most
difficult part of this theorem
was convincing myself that uh two-fifth
is uh bigger than one-third and less
than a half okay
and
you know every once in a while i wake up
from a nightmare and i think i got it
wrong it's actually somewhere outside
this interval and you know
but i think it's it's uh it's between
there somewhere okay but we still don't
have to type down
okay but actually in this paper also
give some argument why this is probably
the type bound so you get some kind of
weird exponent and i don't quite know
why okay
so this is the leaderboard error right
and one thing i find fascinating about
the latter algorithm
is the following simple question is it
prescriptive or descriptive right
is this an intervention or a natural
algorithm is this something the
community implements on its own or is
this something that you should implement
okay
and i'll actually argue that it's both
okay so you could think of the latter
algorithm as like an intervention
that you can implement in a benchmark or
in a competition when you're really
worried about overfitting and then you
get the strong guarantee on like
limiting overfitting so you can think of
it as an intervention but you can also
think of it as a natural algorithm in
the sense of uh you know bernard
chazelle remember the whole bird
flocking stuff
so it's something that the community
does on its own okay and you can say if
you start from postulate about the
behavior of the community you end up
with an interesting outcome okay so it's
a bit of a sociological argument it's
saying like let's start with an
assumption about the community and then
you actually can show that these
benchmarks have more longevity than
worst case bounds suggest okay and this
is also like how you know how i like to
think about it so the apparent like
ignorance of the community or a sort of
obsession with best possible results
has some kind of uh positive outcome for
the scientific well-being of the
community so i found that a little bit
counter
good
so and then something amazing happened
sometime in 2019 a team from berkeley uh
did the following uh as uh ben wrecked
uh rebecca roy loves luke schmidt who's
in the audience and vaishal shankar
decided to do the following uh
interesting experiment
they created new test sets for safar 10
and imagenet two of the most well
image classification benchmarks and they
went back to like the original
description of the data collection
procedure and with like painstaking
effort they tried to recreate new test
sets for these new for these old
benchmarks
and then they evaluated re-evaluate all
the models that have been proposed over
the years on these new test sets
okay
that seems interesting okay so
um what they found and this is striking
is that the model ranking like which
model is better like the performance of
the models relative to each other the
model ranking that had been determined
over the years is preserved
okay
so the the kind of plot they always get
in these things is the following um
at berkeley we call this the ludwig
scatter plot
and um it's it looks like this you have
the old test accuracy on the on the
x-axis and the new test accuracy on the
y-axis and every dot in the scatter plot
is a model okay it shows you the
performance of the model and the old and
the new test set
and it always happens for reasons that
are not entirely clear that these models
cluster on a line
okay
and because this line has positive slope
um you know you know that the better you
were in the old testament the better you
are on the new test set
okay
you also see that performance drops so
the line is below the no change line it
drops because
there's some distribution shift in the
new test set so the performance does go
down but i'm more interested in the
slope of this
line so let's think about this okay so
and i am going to convince you that this
is actually evidence against adaptive
overfitting on these benchmarks
so let's consider the ludwig line
let's look at the old accuracy versus
the new accuracy
and let's just abstract out these models
and let's say we have this line let's
think about the the slope of this line
okay
so positive slope means the following
highest accuracy
on the old data set is also highest
accuracy on the new data set
so in other words if your goal was to be
best on the new data
the thing you should do is you know hit
the old data as hard as you can
okay so if you just like go as hard as
you can on the old data you're going to
be the best on the new data
but it gets even more interesting if you
go to slope greater than one and
actually a lot of the times we see slope
greater than one
which means that the performance drop of
newer models is actually less than the
performance drop
of old of of previous models okay so the
newer the model the higher the accuracy
was the less the accuracy drops when you
go to the new test set
and that is striking because that really
says
even though you had more time to adapt
to the test set you had more time to
overfit there were more adaptive
evaluations against the test set your
performance actually drops less so it
seems like you actually overfit less to
the test set than um you thought okay
and we were intrigued by this and we uh
evaluated this kind of thing or we
we did the scatter plot for all the
cackle competitions and i worked with
sarah friederich carl john miller ben
wrecked rebecca roloffs and schmidt and
vishal shankar and we did this
meta-analysis of more than 100 kaggle
competitions that have been done over
the years and we saw the same okay we
see the same kind of lines and we see
the same kind of uh you know lack of
adaptive overfitting
and even mnist for crying out loud you
know the thing that you might think is
the most overfit benchmark it's been
around for more than two decades it's
been like ridiculed to no end for being
like a toy benchmark even here there's a
beautiful
paper by uh yadav and botu called the
lost amnest digits where they found some
drawer with like extra mnist digits
and they evaluated all the models on
these like lost digits and they get the
the ludwig line okay and so um you know
this is it's it's swapped here because
they swapped the x and the y axis but
this is the same thing it's the same
thing okay so even mnist which is has
seen so much activity
and so it's worth asking what makes
static benchmarks live so long okay why
is it that these like things they put in
the world and forget about for two
decades seem to still work
okay
and so
you know five minutes yeah if you ask me
i would have said well it's the latter
algorithm right it's the latter
postulate it's because we're doing this
leaderboard business and that mitigates
overfitting
but my collaborators at berkeley
wouldn't believe me about the
leaderboard principle and they wanted to
have additional evidence so we poked at
this a little bit more and we identified
like three um sort of principles that
mitigate overfitting and these are
sociological and
um psychological factors and not
necessarily statistical arguments okay
the first one is community dynamics
things like the leaderboard principle
but there's more here the second one is
the mind of the analyst the way the
analyst thinks and that also mitigates
overfitting and the third is problem
artifacts okay things that you might
overlook at first
about the problem formulation actually
have significant impacts on um the
amount of overfitting that you expect
okay
so one thing we can show is
collaboration actually mitigates
overfitting so there's work with thoria
mania john miller benracht and schmidt
we can again start to make some kind of
postulate about the community we could
say scientists have shared priors and
practices
machine learning practitioners try out
similar things
and uh what we see empirically is in
fact this seems to be true a lot of the
imagenet models that have been proposed
have high agreement in their predictions
so let's say you have two eighty percent
accuracy models if you know predictions
or errors were random they would agree
in 68 of the positions right
but you see actually much higher predict
agreement in the predictions
and so we can turn that higher rate of
agreement into better generalization
balance
okay so if you have similar models you
get better generalization bounds so
trying out similar things mitigates
overfitting
second one thing we did is we looked at
the individual analyst and we thought
well what is actually going on in the
mind of the analyst and we're trying to
come up with something that's not a
worst case analyst but like what is a
natural analyst
what does it mean for an analyst to not
behave adversarially okay and then work
with tiana jernik we came up with a
dynamical systems view of the analyst
where we model the analyst as a
dynamical system that takes in
a result from the holdout set and spits
out a new query spits out a new model
okay
and then you get this nice
correspondence between control theoretic
constraints on the dynamical system and
cognitive limitations of the
of the analyst for instance the
stability of the system corresponds to a
recency bias of the analyst whereby the
analysis weights recent information more
strongly
and some kind of lipschitz condition on
the system has the opposite effect it
would lead to some kind of anchoring
bias whereby you sort of ground your
initial fine or you ground your analysis
in initial findings and you try to sort
of confirm them okay
so this is one view of it um but there
is another thing and this is these uh
okay yeah if you if you do this again
you get some kind of
uh you know error bounds that scale
between the adaptive k a non-adaptive
case in the adaptive case and depending
on how strong the cognitive bottleneck
is you're either in the fully
non-adaptive case or in the fully
adapted case so it's kind of some kind
of way of going beyond the worst case
and arguing why sometimes we don't get
these worst case bounds
the third principle i want to highlight
is problem artifacts
you know i don't know if you know this
but like imagenet has a thousand classes
and of these thousand classes i think 30
are terriers okay
and i think no human being has any right
to know more than three kinds of
terriers okay and i don't even know
there should be that many but apparently
there are 30 kinds of terriers
and so they're all these like seemingly
like
similar classes that kind of hard to
distinguish and work with vitoli feldman
and roy frosting who both in the
audience we showed that this kind of
like multiplicity of classes actually
mitigates data over use so we can often
replace the dependence on the number of
data points n by something like n times
m where m is the number of classes
so the number of classes blows up the
effective data set size
but of course you can't just go and copy
your classes you can't just copy your
data set and and then replace the class
names there's some assumption about you
know the priors on these classes that's
you can look at that in the paper
so let me summarize and then wrap up how
many
three minutes
two minutes or three three okay um three
minutes okay so
um
you said you said four
okay four minutes um so meta analysis uh
you know and the benefit of hindsight
revealed that adaptivity was actually
more benign than worst case bound
suggested
and we now have some theory to explain
this outcome
but it isn't purely statistical it's
sort of like interestingly about the
community and how it clocks okay and in
particular it's about you know community
dynamics the mind of the analyst and the
problem formulation and all of these
things
are you know important for what we get
right what what comes out of this okay
and so there are sort of two ways of
looking at it
and i don't know where you landed but i
can tell you where i landed so the first
one is to say
great this is wonderful news it shows
that static benchmarks have surprising
longevity okay so you could say
wonderful we don't have to worry about
it you know these things just keep on
living right
um
but there's the other point of view the
flip side and this is where i sort of
come around to is that if there is
scientific harm
to the way we use benchmarks in machine
learning then generalization gap doesn't
pick up on it
okay
this kind of way of going about it with
like measuring the generalization gap
apparently doesn't show that there's
anything wrong with these benchmarks if
there is okay
and so maybe we should think a little
bit further on like about about
benchmarks and where we expect things to
go wrong if they do okay and so in fact
the benchmark debate is more active than
ever it hasn't gone away and there's
lots of concerns with static benchmarks
all over the place there are many papers
now articulating them i'll give you one
example from bowman and dahl to nlp
experts who wrote a very interesting
paper called what will it take to fix
benchmarking and natural language
understanding and they reflect on many
of the issues with with static
benchmarks but also with newer proposals
of benchmarks
um and so
there was a panel related to this at
nurbs if you want to learn more about
that
i can recommend
and so one of the proposals that they
talk about is what's called the dynamic
benchmarks a dynamic benchmark and it's
a proposal that's meant to replace
static benchmarks so instead of having a
fixed data set
in a dynamic benchmark you keep evolving
a data set over time and the data set
changes with the kind of models that you
propose okay and there are the platforms
like dynabench implementing dynamic
benchmarks okay and so the way this
works in a dynamic benchmark you start
from some data set you let the model
builders build some models you let them
compete
you take the best model that you found
and then you adversarially collect data
so as to fool the best model that you
found
and so you sort of trying to find hard
cases for your current best model and
then you take this adversarially
collected data and you throw it into
your data set and you repeat okay
and the idea is that you somehow grow a
data set that keeps getting more and
more challenging as your models get
better and you get the sort of
everlasting ever-improving uh you know
dynamic interplay of model building and
data collection
and so we wanted to know if this works
and there's disagreement among
practitioners as to whether this works
and so in a recent work with ali shirali
and radiator baby who are both in the
audience we propose the theory of
dynamic benchmarks and it's very uh
simple actually so a dynamic benchmarks
is just a directed acyclic graph with
four operations the operations are model
building model assembling data
collection as an adversarial data
collection and data pooling and you can
stitch together
any uh the benchmark you want from these
four primitives okay
and so uh the standard design that i
mentioned that's currently being
implemented out there is just a directed
path with alternating model building and
data collection steps but in principle
you could you could have anything you
want there and so what we're able to
show is that actually in the standard
design that people implement progress
can stall after just three rounds so
there's no reason to expect that things
will progress beyond three rounds or a
constant number of rounds
and we can get strictly more
improvements with uh you know more
complicated hierarchical designs um but
these are also computationally uh more
uh expensive and so there's a trade-off
between the complexity of the benchmark
and how much progress it can guarantee
okay so with that um i'm going to wrap
up and i want to sort of attract your
attention to sort of this broader
perspective on scientific validity um
and sort of reframing the debate to be
about like what determines the health
and validity of our scientific and
epistemic activities rather than just
like are we overfitting or what's the
generalization gap and there are many
sort of components to this right so
there's the traditional statistical
measures like generalization gap but you
know there are these uh you know broader
issues of problem formulation mind of
the analyst or community dynamics that
actually determine what scientific
outcomes we can we can hope to expect
and so yeah i hope to
get you sort of interested in studying
some of these questions going forward
thank you
hi you said there was an improved
holdout method based on differential
privacy but you didn't mention you
didn't discuss it at all can you tell us
something about it yeah i can tell you
about it so um what's the what's the uh
improved holdout method based on
differential privacy the simplest thing
you can do is uh basically you use noise
edition whenever you report the
empirical risk
of a model you report the empirical risk
plus some noise variable
and you use differential privacy to
analyze
you know what that noise edition does
so yeah it's easy to implement the you
know you just it's just noisy it's a
noisy hold up method so empirical risk
plus noise
oh it's it's in any of these papers uh
you know the one i mentioned with uh you
know uh it's called preserving
statistical validity and adaptive data
analysis
um
if you yeah i i'm happy to send it to
you but there's yeah it's um
i don't have references on my slides but
you'll you'll find it if you search for
statistical validity differential
privacy that'll bring it up
so
yeah
it seems that the ladder mechanism
cannot explain a slope larger than one
on the ludwig line so what is the
evidence that this ladder is actually
going on
yeah so um that's right this is also why
people gave me a hard time about it
so boss is saying the latter algorithm
can't um
you know explain
a slope larger than one the latter
algorithm can't even explain uh you know
this drop right because the ladder
algorithm will bound like empirical risk
and risk so i think for starters i would
also like to have some theory which
allows us to reason about the case where
you keep making improvement but it's not
necessarily close to like
uh the population okay so you somehow
you keep getting better but you still
kind of diverge from the the population
and so yeah the latter algorithm you
know it's a little bit of a you know i'm
a believer but um you know i i have my
arguments um
but uh yeah it's it's not it's not a
full explanation for for more than one
reason one is the one you mentioned the
other one is the the disconnect between
the or the distribution shift that's in
the picture
hey so could you validate your
your
hypotheses about the
effects of the community by using them
as anti-prescriptions
and simply ignore all the community
standards and scientific methods and
try to adversarial win all the
competitions
yeah
uh yes and we did okay so
um there were many people who did these
shenanigans of like climbing the
leaderboard
um and like you know
forcing large errors on these
competitions and yeah it's it's feasible
it's just not what's happening so it's
interesting that you you can really
force it to happen if you try but it
doesn't happen on its own
yeah
thank you moritz william central
[Applause]
the final program for the day is a panel
disc